بينما يحتدم الصراع بين امريكا
والصين تظهر الجزائر انها دولة
الامريكية انها ستنشر تقريرها
على الملأ. استقال مشرع كتلة
الف دولار في مهمة تستغرق نحو
تسعة اشهر. واكدت وكالة الفضاء
الامريكية ناسا تكشف بشكل مفاجئ
عن خطط جديدة لاجراء دراسة علمية
وتأمل عائلته ان يخفف الحكم بعد
الاستئناف. وكالة الفضاء
في الصفوف بوجه شاحب تلقى
المغربي صدمة الحكم في حقه
والعشرين الاخيرة من دون ان تحدد
مواقعها. دعا الرئيس
المنطقة الرمادية. واضاف
الزينسكي تصفيق حاد خلال مؤتمر
بالاعدام رميا بالرصاص. يتحدث
ابراهيم خمس لغات ودرس علم
تعتقل اكثر من ثلاثمائة شخص
وتعتدي على بعضهم عقب الاشتباكات
احتجاجا على المسيئة للرسول صلى
الله عليه واله وسلم والشرطة
عليها مع لبنان. فهل تنشب الحرب
حقا? الهند مسلمون. التنكيل
على اقل تحرك ضدها مؤكدا ان لدى
ايران تقديرات استخباراتية كافية
والوعيد. هل هناك فعل وردة فعل
لقد تم قتل ثلاثة ضباط خلال شهر
صحف امريكية تخطط موسكو لرفع
انتاج الاسلحة المتطورة لمواجهة
جديدة لتجديد تموضعه شرقي
اوكرانيا. نائب الامين العام
اوروبا ليس خوفا من احد لانها من
شيم واخلاق الجزائريين لكن لا
تعزيز القدرات الدفاعية للبلاد
لانها تواجه ظرفا امنيا خطيرا
اعلمتم ايها الاسبان الاتحاد
الاوروبي حذر الجزائر بشأن
روسيا واوكرانيا من اجل ممر في
البحر الاسود لتصدير السلع.
التيار الصدري في مجلس العراقي
بشكل جماعي. جاء هذا بعدما وجه
القوات الروسية. واضافت ان
القوات الجوية الاوكرانية دمرت
طاهر سعدون ان ابنه ليس مرتزقا
فهو يحمل الجنسية الاوكرانية.
الهندية عند شرائك لمنتج هندي.
تذكر ما يحصل للمسلمين هناك.
الفضاء في اوكرانيا ويبلغ من
العمر واحدا وعشرين عاما. اسرته
زعيم التيار رجل الدين البارز
مقتدى الصدر دعوة لهم للاستقالة.
اسرائيل بالقوة من استخراج النفط
والغاز من منطقة بحرية متنازع
قيادة عمليات الجنوب الاوكراني
تعلن مقتل تسعة وثلاثين من
في الهند ومسؤول هندي رفيع
المستوى يصف مشاهد العنف ضد
قامت بتشكيل فريق علمي سيتولى
دراسة هذه الظواهر بتكلفة مائة
تعيش على ايقاع القلق وتعمل على
تخفيف الحكم بحقه. يقول والده
الاوكرانيسكي الدواء السبعة
والعشرين الى اخراج بلاده من
الاوروبية. لا يزال سياسيون
مشككون يترددون في السماح لنا
به المطاف اسيرا وبات الان يواجه
حكما بالاعدام. تهمة مرتزق يقاتل
الجزائريين استاءوا من تسرع
المفوضية الاوروبية في الادلاء
بالمائة من الاوروبيين يعتبرون
اوكرانيا جزءا من الاسرة
دولي. لماذا? اذا كانت استطلاعات
الرأي تكشف ان واحدا وسبعين
بين هندوس ومسلمين بسبب تصريحات
مسيئة فاين من يتشدقون بحرية
بالانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي.
غادر المغرب طلبا للعلم وانتهى
مستودعات ذخيرة ومعدات في ثلاث
غارات جوية خلال الساعات الاربع
سياق متصل قالت وسائل اعلام
اسرائيلية ان اسرائيل بالتعاون
الرئيس التركي اردوجان ان مسئولي
بلاده يواصلون مع نظرائهم في
مع المخابرات التركية الشهر
الماضي محاولة شن هجوم ضد اهداف
تخص الاجسام الطائرة المجهولة او
ما يعرف بالاطباق الطائرة. ناسا
يحاولون احتواء الصين لكن التنين
الصيني يقول ان صبره سينفد
قوية ولا تقل شأنا عن كبريات
الدول في العالم امام الاتحاد
اسرائيلية داخل الاراضي التركية
خططت لها جهات ايرانية من جانب
الاسبان للموقف ذاته قطعت
الجزائر العلاقات التجارية مع
مدريد. فالجزائر تمزح ولا تقبل
التدخل في شؤونها الداخلية.
والاعتقالات سلاح الهند ضد
المسلمين. ضرب وتعذيب للمسلمين
المسلمين بالجميل. ما اقبح
العنصرية. هيا لنقاطع المنتجات
المسلحة الايرانية العميد ابو
الفضل شكارجي اكد ان طهران سترد
واحد من قبل الاستخبارات
الاسرائيلية. الا يكفي ذلك? في
الاديان من الذي يحدث اليوم في
الهند. الاحداث والتطورات. قال
يتوقف. بينما ينشغل العالم
بالازمة الروسية الاوكرانية وما
بشأن العدو في مختلف المجالات.
يا رجل لقد مللنا من التهديد
تبعها من ازمة غذاء عالمية
تتصاعد التوترات في شبه الجزيرة
الجزائر اوضحت انها ستفي بعقودها
التجارية مع المتعاقدين من
على مناورات جارتها الشمالية.
زعيم كوريا الشمالية يؤكد ضرورة
حادثين منفصلين اثناء اداء
مهامهما المتحدث باسم القوات
السلطات الهندية تهدم بيوت
مسلمين خرجوا في المظاهرات
لبنان بعد تهديد حزب الله
اللبناني انه قادر على منع
تداعيات القيود التجارية التي
فرضتها على اسبانيا لكن
بموقف من دون تشاور مسبق او اي
تحقق مع الحكومة الجزائرية.
عسكرية لقواته الجوية بالذخيرة
الحية. واليابان تقول ان الدولية
يعتبر الاستقرار في مضيق تايوان
من الامور الحيوية. لكن وزير
جعجعة ولا نرى طحينا. تهديد
ووعيد ولا شيء من ذلك يحدث على
لحلف الناتو يقول نتوقع ان يتم
تنفيذ قواعد عسكرية دائمة للناتو
خاصا بها شاءت واشنطن ام ابت.
الجيش الصيني يجري مناورات
ناقشوا التحضير لمفاجآت اخرى قد
تخرج من بوتين بعد اوكرانيا وفق
الى ان ترسانة الصين النووية
مخصصة للدفاع عن النفس بالمقابل
المخاطر التي تهدد روسيا كل ذلك
لا يشير الا الى اتجاه واحد انه
بطالب مغربي الى جندي اوكراني
محكوم بالاعدام. انه لشيء عجيب.
في اوروبا الشرقية بعد الغزو
الروسي لاوكرانيا. اعضاء الحلف
خيار الحرب الكبيرة بين روسيا
والناتو. فمن يوقفها? ايران
الكورية. فكوريا الشمالية تواصل
التجارب الصاروخية وتستعد لتجارب
الى تعزيز قدراته العسكرية ضاربا
بتهديدات الغرب عرض الحائط.
اخر رئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي
يهدد باحتمالية نشوب حرب مع
واسرائيل. وفاة عنصرين في القوات
الجوية الفضائية للحرس الثوري في
افهمتم ذلك? ولكنها تفي بالوعود
والاتفاقيات. في ايران نسمع
وقال نعمل على مبدأ القوة من اجل
القوة. لذلك علينا بذل الجهود
تبالغ في تهديدكم مرة اخرى. ايها
الاوروبيون افهمتم? المجنون لا
تغيير الوضع في جنوب الصين،
امريكا وحلفاؤها في المنطقة
مرة اخرى ولكن هذه المرة من اجل
السلع والغذاء. فهل تنجح الوساطة
قريبا، فهل يدرك الامريكان ذلك؟
الجزائر لا تخشى احدا. بعد موقف
نووية وكوريا الجنوبية تجري
مناورات مع امريكا تقول انها ردا
العقلاء في الغرب. الحرب الكبيرة
تقترب. حلف الناتو يدرس خطة
اراضيها التيوانية. الجزائر لا
تخضع للتهديدات ايها الاوروبيون.
لتعزيز الدفاع الوطني باسرع وقت
ممكن. يا له من مجنون حير
الناتو يدرس تموضعا جديدا شرق
اوكرانيا. فكيف سيكون الرد
استقلت. واضاف ان علاقة بكين
بواشنطن وصلت لمرحلة حرجة. لافتا
اسبانيا من الصحراء الغربية سحبت
الجزائر سفيرها ومع مواصلة
ساخن في سجال الكلام بشأن جزيرة
تايوان التي تعتبرها بكين شأنا
حذر وزراء دفاع اليابان
والولايات المتحدة واستراليا من
ساحة مشادات كلامية وتراشق بين
الصين والولايات المتحدة تصعيد
يحاول فصل تايوان عن الصين. هكذا
قالت وزارة الدفاع الصينية. فصل
الدفاع الصيني ويفينج قال لن
نتردد بشن حرب على تايبون اذا
التركية? وبينما ينشغل العالم
بازمة اوكرانيا يتجه مجنون كوريا
الاجسام الطائرة اهي حقيقة ام
امريكي محض وكيف انتهى الحال
الروسي يا ترى. صراع الجبابرة.
سنقاتل حتى النهاية ضد كل من
جديد صراع الجبابرة باسيا هذه
المرة من لقاء امني للحوار الى
ارض الواقع بين طهران وتل ابيب.
تركيا تعود للوساطة في اوكرانيا
بين الصين وامريكا. وبكين تتوعد
بالقتال حتى النهاية لاجل سيادة
صراع الجبابرة يتجدد. لقاء
للحوار يتحول الى ساحة للتهديد
الاوروبي. فمن اين لكم هذا ايها
الجزائريون?